bradley is it true you didn't get your
first acting job till you were 26 years
old
yeah paid for it you mean like payday
paid acting yeah does that
give you like zero hope i mean because
you graduate college you're what 20
some odd years old you know and you say
i'm gonna be an actor and maybe even
when you were in college you tried to
get some jobs and it didn't work out
did you have a cutoff point did you
almost come close to getting out of the
business
yeah i mean it happens all the time it
did like last week i felt that you went
to a good college right
yeah i did where'd you go to georgetown
all right georgetown yeah somehow you
end up in that
actor's studio right that's where you
studied acting that's why i studied
acting
what is that school it sounds like it's
a crummy school no
it's amazing school it is it's an
incredible school and you learn how to
act
i didn't know anything before i did this
play in georgetown where i cried one in
one scene
and i thought it was incredible i'm
outside with the guy my buddy afterwards
smoking cereal did you see i [ __ ]
killed it i was crying it was incredible
the next day we're getting notes for
that night
and we get to that scene and i thought
the director was just gonna be just so
effusive with her compliments
and she said bradley uh okay let's talk
about it was camino rihanna i played
casanova getting cuckholden it's this
nightmare
and she said bradley okay um well
you have to remember to say the dialogue
and you want to make the audience feel
comfortable
not not not you don't want to make them
want to leave the auditorium
and i thought and i realized that i was
just like snot was coming out of my nose
i was so constricted that i was bare i
was probably making like seal sounds
so what you thought was good was a bad
bad and i realized i didn't know
anything i couldn't sit there and watch
a play and say that was good or that was
bad so you went
and you after college you go to that
college with the guy james
so the reason why i went there was uh i
probably wouldn't have gotten in
anywhere they were letting anybody in
not anybody but a huge class they were
letting 60 people and we're like yale
and stuff they let in 12 people i hadn't
done anything
and and it and they also had rolling
admissions which means you could
audition at any any time
of the year right so i auditioned for it
i was lucky enough to get in
and then i had ellen burstin teaching me
wow and arthur penn
you know what are they good teachers is
good teacher incredible are you kidding
me incredible
because she's a great actress incredible
howard i mean
like the kind of thing where you're like
oh you know what maybe i can do this
right you know really incredible i
didn't know jack [ __ ]
so it's not [ __ ] to go to acting
college for me
look some people say you know what i
don't need anything i just show up and
i'm so real
that wasn't my experience my experience
was i didn't know i didn't know how to
look at a script
deconstruct it like nothing i didn't
know anything right and not only that i
wasn't relaxed
i was in my head if you and i had a
scene to do i'm thinking about 8 000
different things
right i'm not and and that what that
taught you was it was really simple it
was really
three year program first year is you
learn how to relax right
second year is learn how to read a
script and the third year is
put those two together and do a scene is
it true that when you were in college at
that actors studio
you actually raised your hand and asked
deniro a question when he was on the
i can see you in the audience asking
questions hold on how you doing mr de
niro my name is bradley cooper
my question is regarding awakenings i
was so nervous for that have you ever
done this where you
if you're at a place and you ask
somebody a question you have to stand up
and then you ask the question and i
forgot to sit down right and
everybody keeps going and i'm still
standing that's what happened at the
actors studio when you were in the
audience yeah
i went back and was a guest there in
october was that the most amazing
triumph of your life to be on that stage
being interviewed by james lipton the
very guy
oh somebody from this class you know it
was amazing uh
and i was really reluctant to do it he
asked me a year prior and i just thought
the cards would be this thick the show
would last 10 minutes i'd feel like a
buffoon
right but after doing limitless i
thought you know what's the point of the
whole show that show is
to talk to the students i thought if i
was a student in there and some guy that
went that was sitting here is up there
that would be incredible